[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrado
[Música]
venidos en primera plana un programa de
radio france internacional y france 24
esta semana ponemos el foco en la
cultura y como este sector ha tenido que
sobrevivir en estos tiempos de pandemia
para ello me acompañan en esta edición y
en este estudio
melissa serrato periodista independiente
especialista en cultura bienvenida a
melissa
ingrid rulo campo a periodista
especializada en cultura también
bienvenida en grid gracias ganas y mi
compañera beatriz jueces que es la
corresponsal del diario 'el correo' aquí
en parís bienvenida a beatriz la cultura
en pandemia hoy en primera plana
[Música]
más digitales más resilientes y más
precarios un año de pandemia ha
transformado el sector cultural con una
doble vertiente la parte negativa
reducciones de plantilla a teatros y
profesionales cerrados profesionales que
se han quedado sin funciones o
conciertos que ofrecer pero también del
otro lado la parte positiva muchos han
descubierto la importancia de la cultura
en confinamientos series películas
libros teatro y música online como
válvula de escape a la crisis sanitaria
y por cierto otro efecto positivo
también el salto en la digitalización
que han experimentado muchas
instituciones culturales hoy ponemos
todos estos factores positivos y
negativos para hacer el balance de la
cultura en tiempos de kobe pero antes
repasemos algunas portadas diario le
parisien cultura un año sin público
también aquí en francia el diario
libération recogen esta portada el
movimiento de teatros ocupados con el
que representantes del sector han
protestado para obtener más ayudas y
sobre todo una fecha de reapertura el
diario le figaro habla de enfado contra
el sacrificio de la cultura dice que
según un sondeo la mayoría de los
franceses
en contra del cierre del sector
bueno melissa ha cambiado la percepción
social que tenemos de la cultura durante
este tiempo de pandemia nos ha cambiado
esa percepción pues yo creo que se ha
reafirmado la importancia de la cultura
efectivamente en el momento en el que
estuvimos encerrados en el confinamiento
absoluto la única alternativa era la
cultura leer ver series ver películas
eso fue lo que nos salvó en realidad en
ese momento pero a su vez creo que hay
que hacer una distinción muy importante
y es que es diferente la producción
cultural y en la industria cultural de
la creatividad es decir los artistas
siguen creando la creatividad no se
detiene la creatividad no depende de
ninguna otra cosa diferente de el
creador y por supuesto su contexto
tarkovski decía que no se crea nunca en
condiciones ideales entonces creo que sí
hay que hacer una diferenciación en eso
pero a su vez eso va a tener una
consecuencia muy importante y es que en
el momento en el que todo vuelva a la
normalidad vamos a tener un atasco
de creaciones porque no haber
suficientes espacios culturales no va a
haber suficientes salas de cine no va a
haber suficiente distribución para ello
entonces creo que en ese sentido hay que
tener muy en cuenta eso claro porque
hablaban desde una doble perspectiva en
gris de una parte negativa de como
muchísimos profesionales se han quedado
sin trabajo
porque no han podido ofrecer sus
productos culturales y también de esa
percepción social de muchos como se han
acercado a la cultura diferentes
productos culturales en este período de
confinamiento hay una doble vertiente en
este asunto sí pues que tuvimos mucho
sufrimiento de estar privados de esa
cultura pero todavía no vamos no vimos
lo que van a dar los resultados de esta
reflexión de esos artistas
reflexionaron encerrados que que vamos a
sacar cuales son van a ser las obras
vivo del espectáculo vivo que van a
salir de esa escritura encerrada todavía
no sabemos el resultado yo espero que
tal vez vamos a ver cosas nuevas cosas
que sean
inventaron del espectáculo vivo pero
también tuvimos
tenemos el pendiente que se da una
escritura seca también podemos
preguntarnos eso también hay artistas
que sufrieron mucho y que no pudieron
escribir ninguna línea pero vamos a ver
lo que vamos a darles está bien la
versión del artista la versión de como
nos hemos acercado a la perfección
social de la cultura y también nos queda
digamos la otra pata del banco que es el
trato de las administraciones a la
cultura durante estos meses de pandemia
es decir se ha tratado bien a la cultura
por parte de los políticos en estos
tiempos de pandemia por supuesto esto es
la pregunta general porque habrá que ir
país por país pero bueno a mirar una
cosa las que más me ha sorprendido de
esta pandemia es que generalmente
francia es un país que siempre presume
mucho de la importancia de lo cultural
la excepción cultural francesa que
siempre le da mucha importancia a todos
los temas culturales y lo que más me ha
sorprendido es que hayan cerrado tanto
la cultura porque en otros países como
en españa han abierto museos aquí todos
llevamos cinco meses sin museos
y las librerías las acaban de abrir hace
nada eso es lo que más me ha sorprendido
porque bueno siempre tengo la imagen de
francia apostando por la cultura y sobre
todo macrón que es un presidente muy
leído y le gusta mucho el teatro y todo
eso me ha sorprendido mucho que te haya
dado este cerrojazo cultural porque ha
costado tanto y os lo pregunto a las
tres entender que la cultura era un
asociarlo con el bien de primera
necesidad ahora recientemente como decía
mi compañera vea es cuando las librerías
también las tiendas de discos a nadie
han abierto pero porque ha costado tanto
llegar hasta este punto porque no se
llega a comprender que la cultura es un
bien de primera necesidad
yo diría que básicamente porque la
cultura siempre ha estado en la última
línea de prioridad de los gobiernos es
decir la cultura cuando es necesaria
para mostrarse internacionalmente allí
sí es importantísima inauguraciones
vamos a ver si son importantísimas y nos
sentimos orgullosos se está reflejado en
nuestro patrimonio y qué
somos como país
esta escultura este artista ha llevado
por obama a otros niveles a nuestro país
pero cuando se trata de verdaderamente
apoyarla de verdaderamente fomentar
públicos hacer crecer hacer hacer
cultura desde el interior de los países
ahí siempre los presupuestos se reducen
ahí siempre el presupuesto va a otros
están estantes a otros lugares donde es
más indispensable digamos más urgente es
más urgente y efectivamente lo es
atender la educación atender la salud el
tema militar el tema armamentista que la
cultura pero pero yo creo que esta
pandemia efectivamente sirvió para eso
para darnos cuenta para confirmar que la
cultura está en el último nivel de
prioridades pero que te tiene que subir
en esa escala muchos critican que
durante estos meses de pandemia ha
habido políticos que han confundido
cultura conocido y han metido en el
mismo saco lo que era abrir un museo con
lo que era
abrir un bar pero también la expresión
existe esa diferencia clara entre lo que
es la cultura y lo que es el ocio
o todavía yo creo que el nivel político
al nivel político de deben pensar que es
un camino ahora que el ocio es un camino
hacia la cultura para los jóvenes por
ejemplo para comunidades tal vez que no
tienen culturas y fácil de proximidad
entonces yo creo que ahí tal vez la
confusión pero también hay ese es esa
idea que puede ser un camino interesante
hacia la cultura como crees que está
bien diferenciado estos dos conceptos
vean
yo creo que no porque aquí por ejemplo
no sé pienso que los museos podrían
haber abierto con un aforo muy limitado
por ejemplo el museo como el louvre que
es tan grande lo que se supone es que
pueden visitarlo al día no sé quién
estás personas tampoco se van a
contagiar tantos en su museo gigante
estricto o en mucho un museo pequeño
igual puedes hacer un protocolo estricto
de empleo pues cada hora que pasen 20 yo
que sé que por lo menos pueden ir 20 por
ejemplo ahora esto durante entre esos
dos confinamiento se abrieron veces al
museo de botones estaba cerrado pero
abrió los jardines del museo y había muy
poca gente y era espectacular poder
pasar por viendo las estatuas con cuatro
personas de en el jardín era una gran
oportunidad
hablando del louvre museos como el prado
o el lugo han hecho una importante
apuesta digital han digitalizado un
montón de colecciones melissa la
pandemia ha servido sobre todo para esto
para un impulso digital sin precedentes
claro porque efectivamente uno siempre
y los artistas anhelan llegar a los
espacios tradicionales de la cultura
entonces un artista quiere llegar al
museo a la galería de la misma manera
una compositor de música quiere llegar
al escenario donde está su público
porque efectivamente es el encuentro con
el público lo que genera la experiencia
artística es ese disfrute verdaderamente
del arte de cualquiera que sea sus
expresiones pero pero en todo caso y por
más de que esté todas estas iniciativas
digitales sean un camino feliz para el
encuentro de la cultura yo sí creo que
nunca en la experiencia artística va a
poder pasar a través de las pantallas
sino que sí creo que efectivamente el
encuentro con el artista el encuentro
con la obra de arte no reemplaza nada
está del lado de la obra de arte no
puede ser sustituido por ninguna
pantalla en el fondo por mucho que
digitalice moss ingrid claro que es una
una obra de arte sin nadie para mirarla
en vivo es una discusión es un diálogo
con la obra
la pantalla nos sirvió mucho para traer
a la cultura a su sofá a su casa a su
cama también podríamos estar en un museo
ahí debajo de las cobijas y eso era muy
muy interesante yo hice una visita de
del set oversight y también del menos a
michelle con un sitio nuevo que se llama
culture book y fue espectacular esta
visita que estaba en mi sofá y estaba en
una michelle allá arriba visitando las
las todas las las torres y todos no hubo
cosas geniales en las pantallas ver si
luego también en los museos también se
han ido innovado no han hecho que se
encuentro se han hecho vídeos en tick
tock para intentar atraer a la gente
joven
puedes ver conferencias a lo mejor antes
pues tenías que ir al museo a verlas
todas las puedes ver desde desde tu casa
pero bueno como siempre es así ves la
gioconda en directo no es lo mismo verla
en directo que
que verla en una pantalla yo voy a
empezar a nefertiti en el museo en
berlín
no es lo mismo verla si estás viendo una
foto después ver ahí pero verla lo que
es en directo y eso y el contacto ese
con la obra de arte y poder dialogar con
la obra de arte en directo yo creo que
no porque la punta de álbum digital
propiciado por la pandemia puede tener
un impacto positivo en el estímulo de
crear un vínculo mucho más fuerte entre
jóvenes y cultura a raíz de que muchas
instituciones se han aproximado a esas
plataformas que consumen los jóvenes
pues por ejemplo el texto que haya
museos ya víctor que es algo que hace
hace unos meses nos hubiese parecido
increíble
pero en ese sentido y sí creo que
también hay que hacer la salvedad es que
de que tampoco es la pandemia no fue lo
que hizo que los que la cultura se
despertará y llegar a las redes sociales
oa lo digital google arte existe desde
que yo me acuerde más o menos desde 2012
es decir
su tiempo atrás pero pero lo que sí creo
es que los museos de lo que los museos y
las instituciones artísticas en general
lo que tomaron conciencia en esta
pandemia es de la posibilidad de
acercarse de hacer que la gente
de despertar la inquietud de que diría
yo y a partir de esa inquietud de
generar eso
lo prohibido es lo más deseado entonces
como en este momento no tenemos museos
entonces si te generan estas ganas de
bueno tan pronto ahora voy a tener ganas
de ir voy a hacer esto voy a hacer lo
otro por despertar si es esa chispa las
instituciones sí que han cumplido
durante la pandemia cosa que no han
hecho siempre los políticos por cierto
bueno vamos a hacer una breve pausa y
enseguida volvemos para seguir hablando
de este balance de cultura en pandemia
aquí en primera plana
[Música]
al devolver a panamá en 1999 la
soberanía sobre el canal que habían
construido los estadounidenses también
les devolvieron la zona una franja de
tierra a ambos lados del canal que
estuvo habitada durante cerca de un
siglo por estadounidense software 6 era
como un pequeño país artificial
construido y dirigido por ingenieros a
pesar de la salida de los
estadounidenses algunas tradiciones se
han mantenido pero también recuerdos a
veces amargos para los panameños pero
nos está acostumbrando a los tiroteó en
la huella de las bombas los niños del
canal favorito de vuelta a panamá esta
semana déjalo por france 24 y france 24
puntocom
france24 punto com está disponible en
cuatro idiomas artículos reportajes
noticias internacionales continuamente
todas nuestras ediciones para ver de
nuevo y el canal en directo 24 horas los
7 días intuitivo rápido y en cuatro
lenguas france24 puntocom liberté
égalité actual y t
[Música]
seguimos en primera plana hoy hablando
de la cultura en tiempos de pandemia lo
hacemos
melissa serrato periodista independiente
especializada en cultura o beatriz juez
corresponsal del correo en parís sin
grit roulotte periodista especializada
en cultura hablamos antes del boom
digital antes de irnos a la pausa y
también hablamos de la importancia de
esta interacción física cara a cara con
la obra que por mucho que demos un salto
en lo digital durante la pandemia
siempre la vamos a seguir necesitando no
tiene un putt
un poder insustituible no me gustó no me
encuentro de ganas de ir más al museo yo
creo y también nos vamos a les permitió
de hablar a una comunidad más grande a
la juventud por ejemplo por todas las
pantallas y las redes esos sociales y
ahí también a los los de edad también
que ya no pueden salir también pudieron
mirar en en pantalla así y ese es
insostenible en sus cifras
el encuentro que cuando vamos a volver a
los museos vamos a poder vivir otra vez
yo creo y dialogar creen que esta crisis
y de asociada a replantearnos modelos
como el de los museos para hacer
renovaciones menos faraónicas más
sostenibles más colaborativas hay un
cambio de paradigma en ciernes que ya
hemos visto con la revisión por ejemplo
a la baja de ciertas remodelaciones
parisinas que estaban previstas y que al
final han tenido que ser modificada
estoy pensando en el grand palais o en
el georges pompidou vamos a cambiar ese
es ese modelo de museos mayas pero que
no sean sesentas masificados como lo
estaban hasta ahora no porque yo irá al
louvre a ver cualquier obra era tenías
tanta gente delante con teléfonos
móviles haciendo fotos que no podías
disfrutar nada no esto es espero que se
reduzca un poco el aforo de los museos o
se controle un poco más
ya lo hacían antes que tenías que
reservar una hora para poder ir a
intentar un poco que haya menos menos
gente para que no sea tan masificado por
cierto hemos hablado ahora de francia de
cómo había tratado a su cultura en
tiempos de pandemia cuénteme qué ha
pasado en sus países cómo ha tratado
colombia a la cultura en estos meses de
pandemia meli
si es complicado pero yo creo que de
todos modos
ante una cosa tan imponente y tan
absorbente como lo es la pandemia
hablar de la cultura sigue siendo
difícil es decir poner poner dinero
sobre la mesa para apoyar a la cultura
no sigue siendo evidente creo que
realmente en donde se encuentra más que
desde el gobierno desde el país en sí
mismo no se puede hablar tanto de eso
creo que desde donde se tiene que hablar
es desde las iniciativas personales de
los creadores entonces creo que ellos
son los que los que ante la crisis ante
la falta de trabajo ante la falta del
encuentro con el público son los que
verdaderamente se han movilizado para
ofrecer eso que saben que para ellos y
para sus públicos es esencial para
facilitarlo para ponerlo a la mano yo
creo que habría para hablar de un
posible balance de cómo ha tratado cada
país la cultura yo creo que habría que
mirarlo no tanto desde el tema desde si
desde un sentido global sino desde las
iniciativas mucho más personales e
institucionales de cada de cada lugar
pero por ejemplo el tema de las ayudas a
lo mejor
queda un poco de tiempo para tenerlo en
perspectiva pero por ejemplo el tema de
las restricciones y quiero podemos
analizando por como en españa sigue han
estado abiertos abierta la cultura las
ayudas que tiene francia no tienen las
ayudas que tienen ya les ha abierto
museos y también han hecho experiencias
con conciertos con un público pequeño
para ver si había contagios o contagios
y bueno luego también en españa depende
un poco de la comunidad porque cada
comunidad autónoma cada región
organiza organizado una manera otro
entonces cambia mucho nos en madrid que
en el país vasco en cataluña depende
pero si en general han estado han tenido
más suerte porque han podido tener
acceso a la cultura no neumático oye qué
os parece que les parece la paradoja de
las ayudas en francia que vista desde
dentro hay tantas quejas al gobierno de
macrón pidiendo más ayudas y vistas
desde fuera desde países por ejemplo
como el mío españa es como apoya francia
su cultura hay una especie de paradoja
en esa visión de las ayudas del estado
francés a la cultura no según lo veas
desde dentro desde fuera
luego ese año blanco que se llama que
fue la ayuda del gobierno a los artistas
y ahora están pidiendo más otro año de
año blanco otro año blanco otra ayuda y
no es sola la apertura que están
pidiendo sino más ayuda y eso es una
excepción yo creo que es ese estatua de
los artistas y es increíble de tener eso
para ellos para seguramente esta
paradoja la que me refiero se hace según
la perspectiva de dónde se sitúe uno no
de como país y las comparativas las
carga el verdad como es decir es
que no hay como comparar sobre todo que
efectivamente francés un país de
reconocido mundialmente por eso es decir
casi que casi no de hecho es un cliché
de la cultura francesa y no el parisino
bohemio que va debajo del brazo con su
baguette pero también alistándose para
entrar a una gran museo y con otro libro
debajo del brazo para no porque eso es
lo que lo que inspira francia desde
lejos efectivamente que la cultura
tampoco ha sido tan bien
y sobre todo no sé si sí es decir pues
que las instituciones y los artistas que
tenían contratos y que tienen como
demostrar que efectivamente trabajaban y
ahí hacían cultura pueden ser pueden
haber sido mejor tratados que esas las
llamadas pequeñas manos los
maquilladores las personas que están
tras bambalinas y que no tienen
necesariamente como justificar y cómo
pedir estas ayudas del gobierno esas
personas sí que han se han visto
afectadas justo eso os quería preguntar
a era porque dentro de la cultura hemos
hablado del boom digital pero claro no
todas las artes tienen la misma
facilidad o las mismas ventajas en ese
ámbito digital es decir no toda la
cultura son las plataformas que todos
nos vienen a la cabeza a nivel cuales
son las artes que más dirían que han
sufrido dura porque las artes o los
empleados estamos hablando es
efectivamente de esas personas que
trabajan en bambalinas que seguramente
son las que más han perdido en esta
crisis
los cines yo creo que la experiencia de
poder ir al cine ver una película
sentado aunque la puedas ver atrás pues
descargar por internet la puedes ver
streaming
no no es lo mismo no de poder que estar
en una sala y toda la gente que trabaja
alrededor del mundo del cine como
hablábamos antes hay un atasco de
películas que están esperando a poder
salir cuando abran los cines otra vez va
a haber tantas películas que no sé más
del que estar en cartelera una semana
porque no va a dar tiempo a sacar tantas
tantas películas tantas producciones en
poco tiempo fue es un peligro porque hay
esas plataformas como netflix y en vídeo
explotaron no todo el mundo se puso a
mirar de eso y encontró el cine que
quería por los algoritmos de netflix
pero en francia tenemos lo que llamamos
la excepción cultural francesa que eso
es obliga a las grandes producciones de
cine o de programas de subvencionar de
financiar a las escrituras más
confidenciales y yo creo que ellas van a
sufrir después porque con la plata las
plataformas ellas orientan y nos dan una
vista del mundo única la vista que
tienen ellos pero las escrituras
confidenciales que son subvencionadas
financiadas por las
producciones esa excepción es excepción
cultural francesa van a sufrir después
cuando todo el mundo va a sólo mirar a
netflix y ya no van a tan a mirar las
otras escrituras de hecho un estudio del
observatorio de la cultura en españa
constata ese incremento de consumo de la
cultura online durante la pandemia pero
al mismo tiempo señala que esto no se
traduce en un incremento notable de
ingresos salvo para las grandes
plataformas como netflix ese es reflejos
quizá lo que no estemos considerando en
la ecuación que efectivamente hay unas
plataformas muy ganadoras pero no son
ingresos para todo el mundo que trabaja
en la cultura
cuando estaban abiertos y todo el mundo
podía verlo pues nadie pagaba ni
compraba el periódico ahora bueno están
intentando sacar dinero de la parte
digital imagino que la cultura pasará
igual hasta que empiecen a saber cómo
pueden sacar dinero por la parte digital
no sé pagar un euro por ver una
producción de en tu pantalla de teatro o
lo que sea imagino que es usted están
todavía buscando un poco la fórmula
mágica como revierten esos euros en las
personas que trabajan que hay detrás no
me gustaría hacer una pequeña ronda para
hablar de iniciativas culturales que
hayan despertado su atención durante
estos meses de pandemia e iniciativas
bueno yo lo dejo libremente y ustedes me
van diciendo melissa
hay muchas efectivamente es decir les
decía hace un momento los los chefs por
ejemplo revelaron muchas de sus recetas
los bailarines es me encanta ahora hacen
masterclass en directo desde instagram o
desde facebook y no es así no tengas ni
idea de bailar puedes hacer la posición
de la bailarina que se yo esté se pero
es bastante elegir una me da a mí que no
te quedarías ni con los chips ni con los
bailarines
es que yo soy fan lo confieso y hay una
cosa que a mí me encantó y desde un
artista que admiro mucho y es que como
yo por ejemplo hizo clases de guitarra y
de canto para los hijos pequeños de sus
fans pues sus fans ya somos tenemos
cierta edad así que bueno él se puso en
línea para enseñarle a los niños
pequeños eso me pareció eso pareció
generoso me pareció me pareció un acto
de bondad porque no estaba cobrando
sabes es como bueno si has oído a tu
papá mil veces cantar este world living
on a prayer y de pronto ven te enseño el
acorde para hacerlo eso pero también la
de edad mito soy fan pero hay veces que
confesar los gustos de uno culturales de
sitúan en cierta generación no hay veces
que dices bueno quizá lo modificó y así
me hago pasar
me ha gustado una iniciativa que es que
empezó aquí en parís creo que es en la
semana pasado así en una exposición de
esculturas de philip que el look del
gato de phil que look
qué son los campos de los campos elíseos
y no por la no será como la oportunidad
de poder ver otra vez algo de cultura en
directo y sobre todo porque también está
despierta una sonrisa como hacemos en
este año que llevamos no han habido
muchas sonrisas pues por lo menos cuando
ves una escultura del gato de de luca
pues no sé siempre te sorprende y tanto
y está estos días en los campos elíseos
ingrid bueno hubo muchas pero el baile
el baile sí porque importante ha sido
bailar aunque sea confinados
es como un homenaje lo que voy a decir
porque es un coreógrafo hip hop que
estuvo pensando que se llama bad sound
que en paz descanse que el durante el
año cuando como no podía bailar no podía
hacer coreografías entonces digo bueno
la cultura y pop es una cultura joven
todavía tenemos los pioneros vivos están
aquí a mi lado en quien tenemos que
escribir la historia para tener como un
libro de todo lo que pasó y cómo nació
ese movimiento entonces él creó los
lives que se llama friends tertsch
comisión que hablaba y interrogaba
entrevistadas y durante dos horas en las
redes sociales los pioneros y el tráfico
podemos durante los meses durante los
meses de confinamiento y eso duró porque
hubo mucho éxito antes es duro
se puede ver está en sus redes social a
él y él quería pues hacer una ceremonia
en un teatro parisino para darle
homenaje a todos los pioneros pero un
hombre una vez más antes de irnos babson
que en paz descanse porque se murió en
diciembre
muchísimas gracias a las tres ha sido un
placer hacer este balance de la cultura
en meses de pandemia y a todos ustedes
hasta la próxima semana quien en primera
plana gracias